hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play flash-frozen
now this is a game that was made I
believe by a college group and I think
it's on the unity engine if I'm not
mistaken and it should be a pretty
interesting adventure it should have a
lot of work put into it and a lot of
interesting unique concepts obviously
you're dealing with cold temperatures
here so it's more of a survival horror
than these indie horror games that
you've seen so far that have like just
tons of jump scares and stuff like that
so look forward to good atmospheric
stuff which is what I've been really
hoping for in the past few games that I
played not that I've necessarily been
disappointed I've been very fortunate to
play some really interesting games and
this one looks like it's gonna be just
as interesting use the right stick to
look around oh you mean my mouse oh they
don't know I tell you use a left stick
to move oh you mean my keyboard wait let
me game that over here blue Wow whoa
work I have my game pad plugged in there
maybe that's why I thought that uh okay
I could understand your mistake there
but I will forgive you for that
nice cards okay sorry
Brewer it's cold I need to get out of
here so I've got my is that my breath is
that my breath uh when I breathe into
the microphone huh that's me I'm doing
that that's amazing it's so realistic
okay press Y to use your lighter
damn it knows I'm glad I bought this
haha all right so I have a lighter it's
my only source of warmth than these dark
cold hauls hmm
hello you're glowing press X to turn the
valve this is amazing I'm so happy I
have this here okay
ah haha what the hell what the hell let
me out hold X I'm holding X look what
the hell just happened okay so what that
said my lighter would highlight some
objects of importance and it seems like
this looks pretty important huh
there we go that wasn't close enough I
wasn't using my muscles alright then so
carrying on nothing strange happening
here water causes you to lose body heat
quickly find a way to stop it from
flowing okay that makes total sense
am I on like a ship or something or am I
on a boat which is another word for a
ship huh who heard haha who's the huh
what what who had I heard someone go huh
what the hell I can't get through here
wait no oh I got it I need to bash my
way through it no oh I missed
sorry about the [ __ ] ranting let me get
this one a good one I need to go good
really focus on this one ah there we go
I was a bit delayed there but just as
good you're cold find a way to get warm
and drink this booze that's how I
usually do it nothing oh ha I didn't
expect that to actually work well hang
on I gotta press X to read as you are
all aware our ship has run aground on a
frozen land formation the ice seems to
go on for miles and currently a steam
has been sent out to investigate the
surrounding area while we await
assistance it is vital stead old crew
keep calm and collected attitude hmm
okay well I got some gas what do I do
about that how do i light flammable
objects I seem to be cold hang on
I didn't read the rest of it remember to
follow standard emergency branch and our
supplies of the sigh Department
consultant for superior we keep alive
but is hold out until help
we will make it through this we will
preserve you mean persevere is that the
word you're looking for good probably
John isn't Doakes well surprise
[ __ ] help ain't coming ok so how
do I survive I'm about to die what am i
doing oh I got it don't know how I did
that I did that I did that I'm great I'm
amazing so am I not cold anymore
oh okay what no hello oh level
transition I thought it was just
standing in the dark there okay we're
okay
ruh-uh hold that number to check fuel
okay so
alright then we got some water over
there that looks like it's about to fall
down is that what's gonna happen first a
to jump watch this sick move here mr.
drebber ah yeah
wait a minute nothing actually happened
nevermind uh-oh
not nothing nice music by the way
there's really nice music okay what is
this industrial solvent okay whatever
there's more fuel for my lighter maybe
it'll keep me just a little bit warm as
I go rule go rue as I go new was this a
dear diary when I took this job I really
thought it would be a good life work a
little see the world become one with the
scene all that stop that without reading
you shut up rude sixty hours a week for
a salary pay pathetic living conditions
worth work my butt off the guests are
having the time of their life you like
to relax fancy food restaurant even take
a drink at Club Katherine's with that
drunk cabinet of ours he's the reason
everyone this ship is so miserable it's
a miracle that he can even stand in the
morning let alone direct his ship with
this size
that's a nice touch getting the weird
sounds as I'm oh maybe that's cuz I'm
freezing I'm about to die this is not
good once again I'm about to die look
sick moves brah all right there we go
hold X to pick up an object yeah
did I pick it up Kurt got it alright
what do I do with it
what am I doing about this stacking up
get up here light it huh Bruce no almost
you almost got it I said a hush this
worked before I know I know this did
maybe if I stand directly on top of it
gosh no can i crouch down light it you
bastard Oh
Boosh there we go okay I got a press X
on it once I get my lighter out so
progress has been saved I'm doing good
so far
what is this
Oh No is that gonna collapse okay good
well that was weird why'd that happen
just gonna randomly melt stuff around me
thank you plenty of fuel cuz I'm a
badass Mike hmm
okay all right then you in for chit I've
got a run ah God yeah light it light it
light it thank you thank you thank you
my progress at the tamed who found me
did Jack Frost find me the Frosty the
Snowman get mad that I took his nose
which doubles as his penis I know it
sounds you need to cut was that saying
that saying so cold
well tough it up you a little whiny baby
[ __ ] your little whiny baby [ __ ] is
burned okay no I shouldn't be so
insulting I have no idea heck I don't
like the cold why would anyone else okay
here we go huh
all right cool moves up don't jump at
the water you will die alright get some
booze hey give me that booze ah I need a
fuel for a drunk minecraft in stuffing
you know you know how it be you know how
it do gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme the damn there we go thank you
thank you
lots of power I got the power
everybody okay so I have enough but I
think there are enough boxes over there
to stack up ha there we go
light it up get some warm oh just get
the booze flowing through the veins and
hopefully one day we'll get out of here
maybe not some people will die to Jack
the Ripper Frost Jack the frost Ripper
who's trying to murder us us me there's
not more than one person here drop it
you bastard draw bat draw Big E son of a
[ __ ] just drop it
there we go what you couldn't drop it
when it was on the ground you had to
drop it from a nevermind shut up [ __ ]
okay just drop it like it's hot there we
go all right
oh there we go all right let's go let's
go let's go let's go
yeah next level or to the end I have no
idea how long this game is by the way
doing good so far
ooh rations well this place doesn't look
nearly as frozen as the other ones so
maybe we'll be ok alright I think I'm
full up on fuel here I've got starch
starch ok I'm going up on the upper
decks which is where all the fancy
people were eating and living there
probably Oh what was that come from
where I come from oh oh that's not good
we'll stop looking at it and go go go oh
oh oh'
can't get me Oh No why died I'll go to
that again you're the one that stopped
me game fine I will wait how do I wait
how do I wait I got use the mouse for
that okay all right then whatever you
say min well that was stupid I was
running as fast as I was able you
wouldn't let me all right whatever
whatever let's just go let's go we got
to cut corners I guess stop looking at
it and go I don't have time for this we
got to go man you gotta go gotta go now
now now now no no no how now brown cow
very now now now now now now now now now
no not off I'm right there you can't
tell me I'm not god damn it I'm running
as fast as I can
I can't run no faster still my legs
won't go my legs won't go what am i
maybe I'm doing something wrong
maybe there's actually something like
running no running is the only thing
that makes sense to me so I'm gonna run
yes good baby good good go go go go go
go go go go go go go go cut corn ah now
get stock no don't go out a gibe what
all sorry for my yelling I I know it's
probably not helping my situation at all
but what am I supposed to do it's just a
lying son of a [ __ ] I'm trying to win
it won't let me I'm trying I'm really am
but it's not out working coz he's being
a stupid [ __ ] and just kind of
standing around
go go go why do you stop running all the
sudden this is baloney
that's his baloney this is below darn
this is baloney this is baloney balls to
the Loney
Oh what am I doing wrong what am i doing
wrong what am i doing wrong what am I
doing wrong what am i doing wrong
I gotta be doing something wrong maybe
maybe if I run and jump up the ah see I
went fast up the stairs that time I need
to run and jump up this hairball okay I
got it I got it I got it I got sit I'm
out I got it I got it I got it I didn't
know I needed to do that but apparently
you do
so when you get to this hold down the
Run button it hit hit the jump button as
you're going up the stairs you'll like
rock it up the stairs
that's much better go go go go go no no
don't slow down run run you bastard
ah I made that I'm the best ever who
ever was
I'm the best there ever was I'm the best
there ever was so why was that down
there in beginning to begin with hold
right trigger - oh okay I got this I got
it
there we go main water shut-off main
water shut-off what does that mean we're
in a ship we're sinking
sorry I'm sorry I shut off the water did
you want this ooh tasty treats not for
me though who needs them who tasty soda
peach passion no time for that we got to
get going let's see
um this looks nice something bad
happened here
oh come on invisible wall really okay
can't go in there Wow nice romantic Oh
was this just a big surprise for our
anniversary it's been four days since
the ship ran aground a real sense of
despair is crept over the crew and the
captain has locked himself in his hole
with his booze and left everyone to rot
one of the engineers is doing his best
to hold everything together but it's not
helping that the captain keeps managing
to crawl out of his bottle long enough
to act like he's still in charge alright
then good for him that a bottle for me
thank you maybe I'm the captain because
I'm a freakin drunkard that would make
the most sense all right let's see here
there's another note over here dear
diary this damn ship is haunted or
something I hear weird creaking sounds
in the night and sometimes I feel like
the walls are moving some of the people
on the ship is starting vanishing - I
keep telling everyone that something's
wrong but no one listened to me I talked
to Ben yesterday he seemed pretty
freaked out about it - problem is I
haven't seen him since no one really
knows where he is the really sad part
though no one really cares everybody's
too busy worrying about and finding
about finding ways to stay warm that's a
really good touch that I do not like
when I'm reading notes playing squeaky
toys or maybe they're always there and
in my mind is just making it worse okay
it seems like everybody just vanished
out of their clothes what's up with that
whatever you think that if it was cold
they'd put more clothes on what whatever
I'm no expert so anyway we shut off the
water what does that mean can I go back
down obviously not well I'm lost they're
not know
I'm sorry was i disturbing you or maybe
I go up here oh that make the most sense
well that was obvious I'm an idiot it's
obvious that I am an idiot that's pretty
much what I'm getting it okay carrying
on so we shut off the water okay more
booze thank you note it's tonight no
funny business no sudden changes we've
all suffered through the drunkards crap
long enough remember Jim and the other
engineers are gonna bring him and the
mates to the bar you all know what to do
remember no vowel ups dial nine for
front desk
okey-dokey thank you all right carrying
on no I apologize okay Gaby
Cotton's mad if I'm not the captain
the captain's pretty upset okay next
level like I said I don't know how long
this game is but it's pretty good I
gotta admit I mean those that was
sequence with the stairs and I had no
idea about oh hello I dialed 9 for
reception okay then this seems kind of
strange what kind of ship is this I mean
I bet on a cruise ship before but this
seems weird
alright then can't play any of those
games so let's just go upstairs ha
there's somebody there and someone
please tell me what the hell's going on
is where they got the this is where they
bought the cabin on the head the
captain's dead the whole peaceful mutiny
hit the fan after the captain threw a
punch at that damn engineer seems like
he was holding together about as well as
the rest of us
it just started slamming the captain's
head into the bar he didn't take much
captain being drunk as usual managed to
knock him out but far too late to do any
good we dumped him the lower part of the
ship the cold will take care of him and
all of us soon if we're not careful so I
am the cabin I just climbed up out of
the ship that's what they did to me
those bastards they left me and my booze
I should have realized when I first saw
booze while I was like booze can I can I
have booze
awesome okay there's never enough warm
clothes to go around food is running low
many have begun to resort to desperate
measures people are disappearing
I almost wish to talk of living ice
wasn't so insane it would be nice to
think I wouldn't have to worry about
falling asleep where anyone could find
me you mean desperate measures like
sleeping together
to huddle together for warmth it's
perfectly natural
okay can't go down that way what is that
okay that's nothing never mind so carry
on carry on uh
carry on my wayward son let's see what's
over here hello is someone here can
someone tell me what the problem is
okay that's pretty well blocked off oh
is that a water main over there
intermittent hang on I saw that okay now
all right let's go go now
there we go all right don't know how
that worked but it did good for us
though
and then I wouldn't think that you could
just know I was about to run right
through that OOP thank you I'm about to
freeze to death actually oh no no no no
no aha gimme gimme gimme come on I'm
about to freeze there we go uh uh yeah
that's the stuff [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I think
I saw it I think I saw an entire wall of
ice just move move like it was alive Oh
guys can't be alive can it I swear I saw
it no one believes me but I'm freaking
convinced as this ship is on it it's
haunted it's just like another sign for
mother nature that we're all supposed to
die a lot of people are gone now people
say that they escaped off the ship in
the dead of night but I think it's the
ice - got him the ice is alive the ice
is alive your ass is alive yes alive yes
okay so he's crazy bonkers he eyes can't
be alive right
whatever you say that's weird how do how
do you explain that that doesn't make
any sense at all all right whatever just
keep going
Oh Nikes okay still alive
maybe for the time being what what what
am I supposed to do here huh don't tell
me but I'm supposed to go this windows
up in here Eminem dude rah there we go
all right so I need to find another
water main to shut off one more level of
water I'm guessing it's over there in
that corner of this area so hook up yep
there we go okay nice main all that
looks very conveniently placed thank you
very much for being a giant dude what is
up with that what would cause a chair to
freezer in the ice like that oh maybe it
was floating I guess I have no idea I
really met a total loss
don't ask me I'm just stupid markiplier
trying to make his way through a frozen
ship okay let me save here so I cuz I
know I'm gonna die okay yeah okay ah
there we go got it got it got it nail it
get it get it get it get it good yeah
alright one more level down man if I if
I could have sobered up and done this
why didn't I do it before I'm some
snitty captain okay there's another note
here wait no this is the same knows
before why was that note over there
maybe to make sure that I read that note
okay but I'm a I'm a gaming professional
I obviously would read the note and why
does the why do those things quiver and
Shake right before they burst water out
of them I don't know weird strange go go
go go go
is there another one okay no there was
not all right go down the stairs here
and try to find a way out of this damn
ship oh this is not natural that is not
natural you can't fool me that would
never happen it would never happen
okay whatever don't care
oh yeah wait do I go out there do I go
out wait what's in here there's
something over here let me find out
maybe there's some secret pup Thank You
booze
no that's not booze it's a bottle of
milk well then what was over here ah
there we go
that's what I needed Oh give it to me
give it to me give it to me give it to
me thank you
alright let's go ok epic jump here no ok
almost didn't make that all right so now
we cross this lobby area to try to get
over here there's a broken entrance over
here and weird water again don't know
why wait no this is the bottom of the
candy shop I don't need to go out here I
need to go oh hello hi there little
whale okay I guess I need to find one
more water main before I'm ready to get
out of here okay so this is all very
normal but I will avoid it okay
oh that's what is this like setup to me
a shower is that a mannequin over there
okay that better not move just saying
just saying that right now that better
not move okay
it wasn't this was the first place that
I came in but there's no there was no
water main oh there was I didn't know
that wait where's uh I need to get
dressed again I didn't know that I was
supposed to get this the first time okay
all right there we go all this water is
just causing my framerate to drop a bit
I had no idea this was here I would have
gotten it a while ago
my bad excuse me
alright whatever got it that's all that
matters I got it and I am good for now
so now that I have that I doubt that I
can jump out of this with us surviving
but I'm gonna try anyway nope just fine
no fall damage I'm okay hello blue whale
how you doing you doing good you look
good woah woah woah why what what's
happening what was that something just
happened my vision just jerked
I don't know what happened there I'm
outside alright good good can I go home
now well I don't think this is any
better I would think it would be colder
out here than in there all right
whatever at least there's no water okay
any notes and he knows go ice skating
for a bit wander around there seems to
be some smoke over there so let's just
try to find our way series of flags out
here hello is anybody home anybody
I guess it's where the rest of the ship
tried oh that's the end this is the
title sequence so cool alright man this
was a very very impressive game I mean
when you went up dense judging on the
past in the horror games and I played a
long time ago or during my time as a
youtuber you know they they come in all
varied statuses of completion and this
was really well done like amazingly well
done I am really impressed by this
especially considering you know it's a
small crew I mean they had multiple
people and a lot of these indie work
games developers there's just one guy or
girl trying to make it and that's really
applaud applaud well and I really
appreciate that but this was really cool
I really liked it it was well done it
wasn't very typical of anything it was
like kind of an escape survival-horror
which is really cool um there's only a
few things it was kind of slowed down
towards the end I would have to say it
got less threatening you know just the
water dripping wasn't very scary to me
but I don't know if this game is like
intentionally trying to be scary so this
was great so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
horn
oh all right
with plays I'm sure it's gonna be love
it's gonna be plenty blighting the girls
out power
I'm sure that has been there going up
Jerry
Gary district
great